the city of Las Vegas is adding a
family-run barbecue restaurant known for
its Food Network appearances to the list
of historical places 8 news now reporter
Brian will got the assignment of the day
right he got a taste of what they have
been serving at John Mull's meats and
roadkill grill for the last 70 years
I'm on Lee what kind of name is that for
a restaurant it was actually roadkill
Grill we didn't have enough room on the
battery so I came back the next day and
you put roadkill Grill underneath the
John Ball's meat it was just a joke man
is the late John Mull's grandson the
fourth owner of this family-run meat
market and famous barbecue joint in Las
Vegas okay so why would he move out here
I think it was cheap it was like a
quarter an acre you know so that's why
he moved out here his grandfather moved
here during the building of the Hoover
Dam and instead of working on the dam he
started a slaughterhouse after decades
Chuck took over in 1981 and introduced
the restaurant side my mom she really
loves brisket my uncle loves the beef
ribs and I don't think people know about
the beef ribs they're like brontosaurus
ribs frequent customers like Michelle
Harris Dixon discovered this spot by
accident and her first visit included a
pretty famous visitor so we go to the
back and proceeded to show me how to
skin the elk and that person was Guy
Fieri the place continues to gain Fame
through shows on the Food Network Chuck
suspects the business will remain in the
family with his daughter Ashley already
saying when I own it as for the business
getting recognized as an historic place
it's a really big deal for my family and
it's a great it's a it's a great thing
to happen for me
but anyway you look at I'll still come
to work they'll be added to the Las
Vegas historical property register on
Thursday sealing their legacy of nearly
70 years reporting in Las Vegas Brian
will
eight news now
okay now it's dinner time they'll be
hosting a party to celebrate the
recognition on Thursday it's open to the
community located up in the Northwest
Valley tucked away in a neighborhood off
Decatur and Gowen